hey guys what's up this is andrew from
jensens.com
so last week was an amazing week guys
for amc
but we cannot forget that even if amc is
the star
we have some very nice breakout signal
on gamestop
so in this video i want to make a big
update on gamestop and show you
all the different scenarios as usual and
give you my preferred one
let's get into it
so let's start on the first time frame
and let's check
what we having here so we had a very
nice week even like the past
weeks were actually very good so let me
get rid for now
of the counting and i'm gonna do it
again with you let me remind you the
situation i did my last video around the
220 level
and i told you that i'm not sure if
we're gonna correct
right now or not that we are bullish as
long as we stay
above this trend line here so for now we
are still above this trend line
and let's see how high we go i told you
that
i doubt we go to do 209 level before
correcting
we went to 270 guys so
268.79
which is very very good guys because we
took some energy
uh we went very high so now we can
correct you know in time and in spot
in a more quiet way i would say i mean
we
the correction doesn't need to go too
low to be a correction
so we're gonna still follow this
trendline here that is gonna help us let
me first remind you a bit
the situation that telling you about
for a very long time so basically we
needed here to break the 200 level
that is uh what i have on the log scale
guys if you try to do it yourself
don't forget to use the log scale
otherwise it's not going to work
so here we have the breakout that
happened here so
uh this is very good this is very
bullish this is the reason why i expect
some very strong moves
to come as well but we have time guys we
have time
we're going to do some idiot wave
counting right now so we don't know if
it's if the one is complete
yet or not that's true so for now let's
say it's a one
okay the two and i'm not sure you know
now that we went here the two can
correct only to here and maybe three
four
five all right we are looking for
something like this this is what we're
looking for this is what we're gonna get
i believe and now we're gonna hourly
time frame guys
basically the what i'm trying to do
right now is to know if the first wave
is complete or not and i'm gonna give
you the answer very soon
at least how i think i can find it and
then we gonna try
to see what might happen this week so
first
let's go here inside this wave
then and let's do some idiot with
counting on the time frame
so one two three four five
easy here abc and here
okay so most likely we're having
something like this
and here our little abcs
okay
and so right now if this is correct
we having a one two three four and so
we're waiting for five
so same a bit like amc let me put it a
different color
so i just wanted to show you how i do my
counting i go inside each wave and i
break it down and i try to find
something that is fitting
good this room is fitting very nicely
because i can find five waves in my
first and
third wave so right now you can see that
here
this went below here so this to me
signals
that this one is complete so we're gonna
have the false wave here coming
same a bit like for amc guys amc was
much stronger but basically those
cycles they happen together i think you
have noticed that
so of course my analysis actually gives
me a bit the same
time stamps for each event to happen so
here
what is likely to happen guys so once
again i think this week is going to be a
quiet week
doesn't mean the market is not going to
move strongly it's just that it's going
to come back to some
levels like magnets so i think the
magnet on gamestop gonna be the 220
level
so i expect probably here
a rebound all right then it's gonna
correct
and here guys is very important what is
gonna happen
either we break this and we go lower and
this actually tells you that the one two
three four five here this first wave is
complete
then we're going to correct a bit lower
probably maybe to the 109 level this is
possible
but if here we hold and actually we go
higher like this
this means we're doing here this fifth
wave so this is very interesting to
notice and we're gonna have the answer
of this very soon
during the week so once again guys here
i expect
a rebound here after the rebound when
the market is going to correct
you know because basically either we're
having an abc
so the abc would be like this
okay abc you know it can be flat zigzag
triangle you know guys right now how
this works
so either we have something like this so
i don't know how high the b wave is
going to go but the higher it goes the
better it is you understand that
because if it goes here then it cannot
be a zigzag it can only be a flat or a
triangle
so let's see where the b wave is going
and it can also be like this
then we can have a zigzag here and then
it can even go higher if this happens
quickly
we can go quickly like this in three
four days and then go higher here
or we already had the small abc
here no sorry then it wouldn't be like
this sorry
it would be like this
okay and then we're doing a one two
three four five
possible as well guys all right so the
second wave cannot be below the first
wave so this is why
220 is a trend line but is also a level
that
if we rebound and then go below it
eliminates this one two three four five
i'm making here
so then we can have something like this
you see
so let's see what is playing out uh this
is possible as well and so that's why
you need to check guys
we're gonna have a rebound i don't
guarantee but 90
chance we have a rebound first and then
either we break
220 or we go higher so if we go higher
it means that what is happening is that
we are completing this first wave that
is actually gonna go
to higher levels if this is not the case
then it means the first wave here is
complete
we correcting either to 220 once again
same thing but
wider longer in time maybe deeper same
as for amc guys
once again those two are going to go
together so you can even use some
signals and gamestop
to make some trades on amc you know this
works
this is what i like to do for example
with the s p 500 i trade on industries
i check the s p 500 if the s p 500 gives
me nice
signals on the upside then i'm gonna buy
some nikkei if the nikkei is down
also euro stocks because i know that
those markets are gonna eventually
follow the s p 500 so when you have two
stocks that move together you can use
one stock to
give you signals on the other one that
works and that is smart actually
so here we can also have this so you
have my two scenarios either we have a
very tight
and short correction and then we go to
300
and then we correct deeper or we already
finished the first wave we correct right
now we go
to re-test either the 220 we stay around
this level or
worst case scenario the 190. look guys
exactly like amc did
i remind you that those two are having
the same kind of
behavior and amc after breaking out
which gamestop just did
it corrected here it retested this trend
line here guys you can see this one the
red and green
it retested it here guys and then it did
the third wave
and the retracement level was quite deep
it was around the 78
feet retracement level so just keep in
mind that this is
what can happen as well on gamestop so
this gives us
actually even the 165 level so i'm not
saying we go there
first because the trend line here is
higher
so this is going to hold the price i
think i don't think we're going to break
125
195 sorry but we still have some bullish
scenarios where
we do so once again this is a longer
term analysis
to get the answers before actually the
market makes the move
we need to zoom in and do the same kind
of reasoning
build you know find the different
scenarios and eliminate them
one by one so once again the 220 level
is going to be key to know what is
happening if we break it we go to 195
probably then rebound
if we hold it then we're gonna hold here
and probably go to
300 level quicker than expected so
let's quickly have a look at the option
market so what do we have
gamestop is now trading at 220
so you see it's more quiet guys we only
have six percent of short interest on
amc we're having 16
of synthetic short so gamestop is
lagging for now behind amc but the
potential is quite huge we can go up to
17
the volatility is at 223 i'm here
talking about the july maturity
so it's much lower than amc we're still
having those
you know crazy uh amount of cool options
on the upside
that to me is confirming that you know
we're gonna have some gamma squeeze to
help the price action develop higher
when the strong moves are gonna come and
we started
the third wave of a larger degree with
counting so it's gonna come
soon i think not much to say here
actually there is nothing new you know
the volatility stays at good levels
so it's actually maybe the time to buy
some
nice option strategies on the upside i'm
going to show you this in my next video
so here yeah that's all i have for you
in terms of short interest
i'm waiting for the 28th of may data to
arrive it is not
here yet the volumes are not that big
guys
13 million shares so we are still
waiting for the volumes to kick in
stronger the short interest for now is
at 26 percent
synthetic on the option market and
regular short interest
so the one month day to cover dtc is at
2.4 and 1.2
for the weekly so once again those
levels are very far from the
short squeeze levels and and i think
that you know the scenario that might
happen to get the real squeeze is first
we go to 800
then the edge fans are gonna short
massively game stuff they're not going
to resist
and then they can get squeezed so this
is what to me
might happen if gamestop goes to the
target of 800
so that's it for me i hope you guys
enjoyed this video and if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button
so you're going to be the first to know
when i upload anything new
and stay close to shore i see you guys